hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to eternal walk now I found
this game on heo and it seemed
interesting judging by the face in front
of me in the spazzing out name but who
knows once we get into it it might be
crap it might be great Oh God the
typical controls of every game ever made
watch your back
sometimes the shadows can stalk you run
if the ambience becomes creepy when you
finish your goal go back to the entrance
at the beginning ok seems good enough
I'm ready I don't know why we're doing
enter what the [ __ ] yes oh what the [ __ ]
whoa where am I okay this is a little
bizarre I had no idea this was what it
was gonna be like hello it's been a long
time since I played an indie horror game
like this you know one that drops you
into a narrow corridor kind of dungeon
style thing with no real explanation and
there's some interesting way hello oh hi
how are you doing
I got a cassette why am I getting a
cassette for what purpose is this happen
is this a slender tool god
yes not just me that's a wall shaking
why are the wall shaking okay you know
when you drop me into a pot like this
and you don't explain anything two
things can happen it can either be
really stupid or it can be suddenly very
creepy and this kind of took that ladder
route
what did it say if the oh jeez why are
the walls shaking
why am I in here and and why am i
holding like a femur bone is my hand no
I don't think I want to know when I run
I can run okay I hear something that's
like high what the [ __ ] was that
was that a thing what was that so
something I actually need to be worried
about her is that just random
occurrences something tells me that was
not random [ __ ] hello open room that's a
big change
okay how nice it's so bizarre that this
game is like entirely played on the
bottom part of the screen here I don't
know how I'm gonna be able to find all
the cassette hello I found another
cassette Wow
good for me do I get a prize is the
prize death I think it's okay alright
okay I saw something out of the car
goddamnit hi umm thing that was is there
you better not be there anymore
pause that okay now that I got better
bearings about it I don't know if it was
actually anything and if I was as scared
away oh I thought I was dead
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is happening
I can't tell if this game is actually
well-made or not well-made miss is
bugging out I stop screaming at me there
is no need there is no need I'm a nice
guy you can just ask me politely uh I I
don't am I going in circles here or what
is it oh hey okay that's another one but
I I think I'm being stalked yeah yeah
hello is there someone here I can't
exactly say it's using cheap jump scares
because I don't know why
Oh oh god damn it
ah can't see can't see headphones fell
off can't hear well can't deal with it
now get a run what the [ __ ]
holy poop okay I'm in the clear oh jeez
what happened to my head
why is my head so lubricated that my
headphone [ __ ] fly off
I hear that even not on my headphones on
god damn it oh I can't stop again sup
I'm in a crisis I don't know where I am
I lost completely is happening anymore
oh why is it thing after me okay I don't
know I don't know where I've been D we
all gotta [ __ ] oh god damn it what the
[ __ ] happened how was I supposed to
avoid any of that oh geez Oh what the
hell like my sensitivity went way down
all the sudden what had happened there
suddenly my sensitivity on my mouse is
way lower than it was I'll give this one
more try but I don't know I don't know
about this alright let me just get this
okay I'm obviously back at the beginning
and I think I sort of understand at the
hand the arm is a hand holding a lantern
at least that's my understanding about
it so I just got to generally skedaddle
along here find the few cassettes that I
can and don't be cornered but it's kind
of hard to kind of hard to avoid when
there's narrow corridors and the other
thing seemed to be sprinting at me Oh
like this like this but then again like
I said before at the beginning of this I
have not played a game like this in a
long time oh I think there's actually
one over here hey hi
Wow it's like one
we do scream in my ear
hey that's Wario Christmas don't do that
what are you ah hi okay you're like
impossible to avoid [ __ ] off with you
oh you creepies twitchy bastard get
outta here ah man okay man that is weird
now that I'm now that I'm getting used
to it like I can obviously see some of
the some of the faults of this game
there was again I sound like the two
circles so he's gonna be coming at me
come on come on me bro
what are you got what do you got you got
anything you got nothing
where to go [ __ ] sit down this hallway
no I'm gonna run smack it
okay I know where you are now yes creamy
[ __ ] your sprint my god
got a chargeability but it's on a
cool-down they can't get me okay so this
is leads back to the big open corridor
area and does let me see if there's like
another way to go around here I don't
think there is either what is okay so
now that I got these cassettes maybe I
can get to the end of this but I highly
doubt it home and be lost in this maze
oh god damnit branching paths [ __ ] me
hope there's another one got it good
buddy get out you know push him out of
the way I'm bushi out of the way
how much health I have left when it
can't be alive okay I didn't think I was
gonna be anything new
Oh
enter the plane of non-existence yeah
[ __ ] dude the last guardian of the
cassette tape here it's gotta be a door
just along this wall here I meant we're
here there we go okay got it
okay well that was fun that was an
excursion do jeezum z'
stop with your charged with you oh god
damn it I've got one more oh I'm not
gonna make Jesus tell me about the
Eagles [ __ ] I think I went a wrong way
yeah I wonder on floor
ah [ __ ] off and one more I'm not doing
it again okay okay all right okay uh I'm
not gonna try to do that again mostly
because I was wandering there for quite
a while just trying to find it as it is
um and as I was playing along it like it
got me in the beginning and I'll give it
full credit for that it got me in the
beginning but once I started to see more
of the game I saw the obvious flaws that
were poking through the holes in the
structure of the game that's not to give
it any discredit let's be honest for
those of you who know how many indie
horror games I've played in the past
I've played way worse than this and I'm
not even saying this is too bad it's
just could use a little more polishing
something a little more interesting than
a box like maze but still it got me so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more of this you can
check out the link in the description
below buddy he heard I was talking [ __ ]
about him so you can see more of it as
he nibbles my giblets into destruction
and thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see some of
these older indie horror games that I
played there's a big ol playlist with
over 200 videos of scary games that I
played in the past
so check that in the description and
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye